bonjour à tous
que vous allez bien on se retrouve
aujourd'hui pour la vidéo faq 200
l'abonné qu'est-ce que vous voulez que
je vous dise deux cent mille abonnés on
était à 38 l'abonné à peu près au début
de cette année
je sais pas ce qui se passe je sais pas
ce qui se passe sur cette chaîne mais en
tout cas ça va beaucoup trop vite pour
moi
et malheureusement je ne peux rien vous
dire d'autre que les banalités d'usagé
c'est à dire merci merci beaucoup pour
votre soutien merci pour votre fidélité
cette année a été incroyablement riche
incroyablement intense
je peux même vous dire qu'à titre
personnel ça a été l'année la plus
intense de toute ma vie et je pèse mes
mots je ne sais pas ce que nous réserve
l'année prochaine mais une chose est
sûre cette année fut incroyable et j'ai
bien envie de continuer sur cette lancée
de continuer avec vous qui a de plus en
plus nombreux à me soutenir et
d'ailleurs avant de commencer à répondre
à vos questions j'ai quelques annonces à
vous faire la première annonce vous êtes
déjà nombreux à le savoir c'est que
désormais mes vidéos sont disponibles en
podcast vous avez été très nombreux à me
faire cette demande à me demander à ce
que mes vidéos soient disponibles en
podcast
puisque pour la plupart vous écoutez mes
vidéos davantage que vous ne les
regardez et donc grâce à l'aide d'un
abonné d'ailleurs je le salue merci à
toi david et bien on a mis en place ce
transfert de toutes les vidéos de
youtube vers les plates formes de
podcasts donc vous pouvez m'écouter que
ce soit sur spotify que ce soit sur
deezer que ce soit sur apple podcasts et
d'ailleurs j'en profite pour vous
demander de bien vouloir laisser une
note de laisser un avis de laisser un
commentaire sur la plate forme de
podcasts ou vous m'écoutez parce que
c'est ça qui va participer au
référencement évidemment plus mais audio
plus mes émissions apparaîtront dans les
recommandations et plus elles seront
susceptibles de toucher un large public
donc respect pour la première annonce
est maintenant la deuxième annonce qui
est la plus importante et qui à mon avis
va faire sans réjouir quelques-uns c'est
que après analyse de l'évolution de la
chaîne cette année si la tendance se
maintient sur la fin de l'année je parle
ici en année académique non pas en année
civile c'est à dire que si la tendance
se prolonge jusqu'à cet été et bien
partir de l'année prochaine
je vous annonce que je serai en mesure
de vivre de la chaîne youtube
c'est à dire que je pourrais me conte
sacré à plein temps à la réalisation des
vidéos pour ceux qui me suivent
vous le savez déjà j'ai un autre métier
à côté de youtube
je suis professeur particulier je donne
des cours de philosophie et je ne prends
pas la décision d'arrêter les cours
particuliers à la légère pour moi c'est
quelque chose qui doit être réfléchie et
qui doit être basée sur du solide et
étant donné que vous êtes de plus en
plus nombreux à ma portée votre soutien
que ce soit par tipi ou que ce soit par
le système des souscriptions c'est à
dire des abonnements premium et bien
votre soutien fait que je suis
maintenant en mesure financièrement de
me consacrer exclusivement à la
réalisation de mes vidéos
alors évidemment je ne vais pas arrêter
d'exercer mon métier dès cette année je
vais évidemment attendre la fin de
l'année je ne vais pas lâcher mes élèves
en cours de route surtout dans un
contexte qui n'est pas facile pour eux
en ce moment mais si avant l'été je me
rends compte qu'il est possible pour moi
d'arrêter en tout cas temporairement mon
métier de professeur particulier pour me
consacrer entièrement à youtube et bien
je le ferai je le ferai ce qu'il veut
dire que à partir de septembre
vous aurez toujours votre vidéo
hebdomadaire mais vous en aurez
peut-être une deuxième vous aurez
peut-être des vidéos plus travailler
peut-être même plus longue donc c'est
mathématique évidemment plus vous êtes
nombreux à me soutenir
plus je peux libérer du temps et à
partir du moment où je n'ai plus besoin
de travailler à côté de youtube jeu
comme consacrer à plein temps à cette
activité et je vous cache pas que ce
serait pour moi quelque chose d'assez
extraordinaire c'est très important de
le dire
si je peux aujourd'hui envisagé de me
consacrer à plein temps aux vidéos
c'est grâce à vous c'est grâce à votre
soutien donc merci au type heures merci
aux souscripteurs
merci à tous les donateurs ponctuelles
merci à vous tous qui avez rendu cette
évolution possible
et croyez moi que je n'oublierai pas
voilà les annonces sont faites
on va maintenant pouvoir passer au vif
du sujet et réponses à vos questions on
y va c'est parti première question est
une formation ou des diplômes en
philosophie oui j'ai un master en
philosophie et j'ai fait mon mémoire de
master en philosophie morale et
politique sur le sujet du libéralisme
contemporain
peux tu nous parler de l'avenir de la
chaîne et si de nouveaux projets verront
le jour
bon j'ai déjà répondu en grande partie à
cette question en préambule
donc ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
je vais continuer les podcasts
philosophique sur les hauteurs et il est
possible qu'à l'avenir je traite une
semaine sur deux non pas d'un auteur
mais d'un sujet d'un sujet général sur
lequel je vais vous proposer mon analyse
personnelle parce que vous êtes très
nombreux à me dire mais charles quand tu
nous parles d'un sujet quand tu nous
parles d'un concept toi qu'est ce que tu
en penses
et pour moi cette question jusqu'à
présent elle n'avait pas vraiment lieu
d'être
parce que mon travail ma mission
ce n'est pas de vous dire ce que je
pense parce qu'à la limite on opinion on
s'en fout mon travail c'est de vous
transmettre des connaissances de vous
transmettre de la matière à réflexion de
la matière à penser penser et peu parce
que je ne veux surtout pas être dans le
rôle de celui qui va vous dire ce que
vous devez penser ou comment vous devez
penser ça c'est pas mon travail et je
veux absolument éviter ce travers que
j'observe chez de nombreuses personnes
dès lors qu'elles ont un petit peu de
notoriété et pour ma part il est hors de
question que je m'érige en une sorte
d'autorité qui va faire sa profession de
foi c'est pas du tout mon truc c'est pas
du tout la direction que veut donner à
cette chaîne parce que moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est de vous donner des
outils qui vont vous rendre autonome
dans la pensée autonome dans la
réflexion je ne veux surtout pas que
vous vous affilier à ma propre pensée et
je ne veux surtout pas que vous voyez en
moi une sorte de mentor une sorte de
gourou de maître à penser que vous allez
suivre aveuglément ça c'est exactement
le contraire de ce que j'essaye de
promouvoir sur ma chaîne ce que je
promets sur ma chaîne c'est l'autonomie
intellectuelle c'est l'indépendance
d'esprit et à ce titre il est hors de
question que ce soit moi qui vous disent
que vous devez penser
en revanche cela n'exclut pas que je
puisse faire de temps à autre des vidéos
où je vais vous livrer une réflexion
personnelle mais cette réflexion
personnelle elle sera évidemment nourris
de mes influences philosophique elle
sera nourrie de tous les auteurs dont je
vous aurais parlé sur la chaîne mais
avant d'en arriver là c'est à dire avant
de vous livrer une analyse personnelle
sur tel ou tel sujet bien je tiens à ce
que vous ayez et que vous me
zié les outils philosophique que
j'utilise dans ma propre réflexion
c'est à dire que arrivé et vous balancer
ce que je pense vous dire ce que je
crois bien ce que je crois mal ce que je
crois vrai ce que je crois faut ça n'a
aucun sens si vous n'avez pas les outils
pour évaluer pour examiner pour
soumettre au jugement critique tout ce
que je pourrai vous dire je vous cache
pas que parfois je prends un malin
plaisir à aller à l'encontre de ce que
certains d'entre vous attendent de moi
en termes d'argumentation en termes de
discours parce que je ne veux absolument
pas que vous puissiez reconnaître en moi
quelqu'un que vous allez suivre de
manière aveugle c'est à dire sans faire
fonctionner votre esprit critique
donc tant mieux si vous n'êtes pas
d'accord avec moi tant mieux si parfois
vous êtes déçu parce que je dis si
parfois vous avez l'impression que je
suis à côté de la plaque
tant mieux parce que plus vous serez
déçu et plus vous serez en désaccord
avec moi et moins vous risquerez de me
considérer comme une sorte de penseurs à
suivre ou de référence intellectuelle
non c'est à vous d'être votre propre
référence c'est à vous d'être votre
propre modèle et tout ce que je peux
vous dire c'est n'allez pas chercher
dans d'autres individus ce que vous
devez être ou ce que vous devez penser
écouter tout le monde mais ne croyez
personnes écoutez tout le monde mais
fait d'abord confiance à vous même et
enfin au niveau des projets qui verront
jours sur la chaîne je vous avais
annoncé je n'ai pas oublié un nouveau
format d'épisodes qui verra le jour
peut-être j'espère avant l'été c'est le
format des portraits philo c'est à dire
que je vais choisir un personnage ou une
icône de la culture populaire ou
historiques
donc ce seront des vidéos semi ludique
c'est à dire des vidéos un petit peu
amusante qui n'auront pas le côté
sérieux ou académique de certaines de
mes analyses et puis ce sera également
pour vous l'occasion de réviser vos
classiques en tentant de découvrir
quelle philosophie se cache derrière tel
ou tel personnage question suivante que
penses tu du principe des vidéos
sponsorisées les op partenariat alors
personnellement je n'ai rien contre les
partenariats ou les opérations
sponsorisés tout simplement parce que je
considère que chaque vidéaste gère sa
chaîne comme il l'entend alors il se
trouve qu'à titre personnel j'ai été
contacté par des célèbres marques qui
ont l'habitude de sponsoriser des
youtube heures
une certaine marque de jeux vidéo une
certaine marque de vpn que vous
connaissez j'ai refusé ces deux offres
tout simplement parce que vient déjà les
produits en question ne sont pas des
produits que j'utilise à titre personnel
donc je me sentirai totalement
illégitime est mal placé pour les
défendre
et aussi parce que ses marques n'ont pas
grand chose à voir avec l'esprit de ma
chaîne donc je n'exclus pas
catégoriquement d'accepter un jour des
opérations sponsorisés mais il faudra
tout simplement que la marque ou que le
produit s'intègre de manière logique et
cohérente dans le contenu que je propose
question suivante comment as tu été
amenés à te cultiver autant sur ces
sujets études lecture personnelle
question d'adrien bien coûte moins cher
adrien je te répondrais un petit peu des
deux c'est à dire que j'ai construit
l'essentiel de ma culture philosophique
et même littéraire pendant mes années
d'études c'est à dire entre 2004 et 2011
puisque j'ai fait un master j'ai fait
une première année de doctorat
j'ai volontairement redoublé une année
de maîtrise et une année de master parce
que justement je voulais prendre du
temps pour me cultiver pour assister à
d'autres cours des cours de sociologie
des cours de psychologie
donc c'est essentiellement pendant ces
sept années que j'ai bâti ma culture
philosophique et littéraire est par
ailleurs j'ai aussi eu des lectures
personnelles alors principalement des
romans aussi des essais et on va dire
que tout ça mélangé ma culture
universitaire avec ma culture
personnelle a fait qu'aujourd'hui j'ai
un petit peu de matière qui me permet de
pouvoir parler en improvisant sur tel ou
tel auteur ou sur tel ou tel concept
en revanche puisque tu me donne
l'occasion de répondre à cette question
je tiens à signaler quelque chose qui à
mon avis n'a pas été compris par
certains d'entre vous qui est que en
réalité et toutes proportions gardées
je n'ai pas une culture littéraire même
philosophique extrêmement étendue le
principal atout de mes vidéos de ce que
je propose sur youtube
ce ne sont pas tant les connaissances ce
n'est pas tant la culture c'est plutôt
la manière dont j'initie une réflexion
et la manière dont j'essaye de vous
intégrer au processus de la réflexion la
principale compétence ce ne sont pas mes
connaissances ma principale compétence
c'est d'être capable de transmettre des
éléments de réflexion de transmettre des
logiques de penser et de le faire dans
les termes qui soit accessible et
compréhensible par le plus grand nombre
et ça évidemment c'est lié à mon métier
alors est-ce que je suis pédagogue parce
que je suis professeur ou est ce que je
suis devenu professeur parce que j'aime
la pédagogie c'est un peu comme le
problème de l'oeuf ou de la poule mais
en réalité je ne suis pas ce qu'on
appelle un érudit
le fait est que j'ai une assez bonne
mémoire qui fait que quand quelque chose
va m'intéresser
je vais m'en souvenir mais je vais
surtout me l'approprier me l'approprier
intellectuellement et c'est ce qui va
faire ensuite que je vais être capable
d'exposer une pensée de restituer un
raisonnement en improvisant donc je sais
que quand on fait référence à des
philosophes ou quand on donne des
citations ça donne tout de suite
l'impression qu'on est quelqu'un
d'extrêmement cultivées en fait pas du
tout pour ma part je ne m'estime pas
être quelqu'un de particulièrement
cultiver tout simplement parce que j'ai
conscience qu'il y a des tas de domaines
de la culture sur lesquels je n'ai
aucune connaissance sur lesquels j'ai
même de grandes lacunes et donc ça
m'arrivera très souvent de discuter avec
quelqu'un que je vais écouter pendant
une heure parce qu'il va me parler d'un
sujet sur lequel je n'ai aucune
connaissance
donc évidemment il ya une déformation de
la perception qui est lié au fait que
dans mes vidéos vous parle de choses que
je connais je vous parle de choses que
j'ai étudié ou sur lesquels j'ai
beaucoup réfléchi
donc ça donne cette impression de
maîtrise ça donne cette impression de
culture et de connaissance mais qui se
limite aux domaines de la philosophie
des lettres et à une partie de la
culture générale
question suivante bonjour quelle est la
méthode pour construire le contenu de
tes vidéos
alors ça j'en ai parlé sur mon compte
instagram et d'ailleurs j'en profite
pour vous dire de vous abonner en masse
à mon compte instagram parce que c'est
sur ce réseau social là que je publie le
plus souvent des nouvelles que j'annonce
le thème des prochaines vidéos et donc
j'ai décrit dans l'une de mes story le
processus de réalisation de mes vidéos
donc j'explique d'abord bien tout
commence avec une idée c'est à dire que
alors que je suis en train de faire
complètement autre chose alors que je
suis en train de conduire alors que je
en train de manger ou de brosser les
dents une idée me vient et à partir de
là s'enclenche le processus de
préparation au niveau de la préparation
c'est très simple
je prends une feuille je prends un stylo
je note mes idées principales et
j'essaye de faire quelque chose d'assez
global d'assez général c'est à dire que
je ne commence pas à rédiger ce que je
vais dire en vidéo mais vidéo ne sont
pas scriptés elles ne sont pas écrites
elles sont préparées dans la mesure où
j'ai la liste des idées principales que
je souhaite aborder une fois j'ai
terminé cette préparation est bien à ce
moment-là j'enregistre j'enregistre en
improvisant et j'enregistre pendant une
durée qui peut aller d'une à deux heures
et c'est ensuite au montage lorsque je
fais le montage de ma séquence audio et
bien que je vais couper que je vais
supprimer les aspects superficiels
tout ce qui va peut-être alourdir la
compréhension tout ce qui risque en
réalité de vous faire perdre votre
attention et donc je ne garde que la la
substantifique moelle et je fais
également très attention comme vous
l'aurez sans doute remarqué au rythme
demande élocution c'est à dire que je
privilégie volontairement un rythme lent
tout simplement parce que la pensée est
lente et parce que faire des vidéos de
philosophie trop rapide trop rythmé trop
dynamique là pour moi ça va à l'encontre
même de l'esprit philosophique qui est
la patience la patience du concept la
patience de la pensée pour moi c'est ça
en fait qu'il fait là la particularité
de la pensée profonde et c'est ça que
j'essaie de restituer dans mes vidéos
question suivante quelle est la question
philosophique qui te fascine le plus
alors ça c'est une question très
difficile pour y répondre je vais déjà
faire un petit historique à savoir qu'au
départ ce qui m'intéressait dans la
philosophie c'était davantage la
philosophie morale puis la philosophie
politique parce que pour être tout à
fait honnête et transparent avec vous
vous avouerez qu'au début la
métaphysique ça m'emmerdait profondément
ça m'ennuyait je ne voyais pas l'intérêt
parce que pour moi c'était trop abstrait
pour avoir un sens et donc je
m'intéressais davantage aux applications
pratiques de la philosophie c'est à dire
principalement la morale et la politique
avec le temps mon point de vue a bien
entendu évoluer et je pense que certains
d'entre vous auront remarqué que j'ai un
un goût particulier une inclination
particulière pour la métaphysique mais
ça c'est venu avec le temps force
d'expérimenter à force de
intéressée au concret on a envie de
prendre du recul sur les choses
on a envie pour le dire comme ça de
prendre de la hauteur et la métaphysique
ça consiste à prendre de la hauteur
justement et à essayer de comprendre le
monde dans ses structures et moi je
dirais que c'est ça qui m'intéresse
particulièrement philosophie c'est la
question des structures
c'est à dire que la métaphysique n'est
pas lié aux contingences temporel la
métaphysique n'est pas lié aux
circonstances du moment à l'actualité
et moi quand on vient me demander mon
avis sur l'actualité j'ai envie de
fermer ma porte
parce que ça m'intéresse pas parce que
l'actualité c'est ce qui ne sera plus
valable demain c'est ce qui ne sera plus
valable dans une semaine
donc j'estime que c'est une perte de
temps ou pour répondre à ta question je
dirai que la question philosophique qui
me fascine le plus c'est la question du
sens et la question de la capacité de la
conscience humaine comprendre le réel
ça peut paraître idiot mais pour pouvoir
étudier le monde et pour pouvoir le
comprendre il faut déjà un pré requis il
faut que le monde soit compréhensible
c'est à dire qu'il faut que le réel se
comporte de manière rationnelle
parce que si le real n'était pas
rationnel il ne serait pas
compréhensible et moi c'est quelque
chose qui me fascine le fait que le réel
soit intelligible qu'il se comporte de
manière rationnelle et que nous autres
êtres humains nous soyons doté de cette
fonction rationnelle qui nous permet de
comprendre et de décoder le monde sait
galilée qui disait que le livre de la
nature était écrit en langage
mathématique et ça c'est quelque chose
qui me passionne c'est à dire la
structure de l'univers
la structure intelligible de l'univers
et le fait que l'univers soit
préhensibles pour la conscience parce
que quand on y réfléchit c'est tout sauf
une évidence le fait que nous soyons
doté de cette antenne qu'on appelle la
raison que les grecs appelé le logos et
qui nous rend capables d'être en
connexion avec le monde qui nous rend
capables de comprendre ses mécanismes et
de comprendre sa structure
ça c'est quelque chose qui me fascine
absolument par exemple le fait que l'on
puisse modéliser des trajectoires
astronomique avec des équations
mathématiques
ça me pousse à m'interroger quel est le
statut des mathématiques par rapport à
la réalité
est ce que la réalité de nature
mathématiques ou est-ce que c'est nous
qui avons inventé les mathématiques pour
décrire le comportement du réel mais
dans ce cas là comment se fait-il que
les mathématiques soit aussi infaillible
soit aussi efficace dans la restitution
du comportement du réel ça pour moi
c'est quelque chose de fascinant et je
ne vous cache pas que c'est une question
que je vais continuer à creuser et
notamment dans une vidéo qui va arriver
très prochainement question suivante à
partir de quel moment pouvons-nous être
désigné par le terme philosophe light
suffit de prendre à ton compte
la définition de pythagore pythagore
disait le philosophe c'est l'ami de la
sagesse à ne pas confondre avec le sage
le philosophe n'est pas le sage le
philosophe c'est celui qui aspire à le
devenir
donc à partir du moment où tu es dans
une démarche de compréhension du monde
et d'adaptation de ton comportement à la
nature du réel tu es déjà dans une
démarche philosophique être philosophe
ce n'est pas avoir une culture
philosophique être philosophe ce n'est
pas de connaître les citations des
philosophes être philosophe c'est
pouvoir proposer une vision du monde
pouvoir proposer une lecture de la
réalité émettre des actes en adéquation
avec cette vision du monde donc c'est
pour ça que je dis que nous sommes tous
potentiellement philosophe et si à titre
personnel je récuse ce titre parce que
philosophe est aussi utilisé comme un
titre j'assume complètement d'être
philosophe au sens où je m'inscris dans
une démarche de compréhension du monde
face à la dictature de l'émotion dans
nos sociétés souffrent faut-il faire
appel à plus de philosophie alors ça
c'est une question très intéressante la
dictature de l'émotion une dictature de
l'émotion dont je préciserai qu'elle est
alimenté en grande partie par la logique
médiatique
c'est à dire par la logique de la
réaction vous êtes tous des utilisateurs
des réseaux sociaux pour la plupart et
vous savez que ce qui est recherché sur
les réseaux sociaux c'est la réaction
la réaction qu'est ce que c'est c'est le
règne de l'instantané
c'est le règne de l'éphémère c'est le
règne du passager et la réaction par
définition c'est l'absence de recul
c'est l'absence de distance c'est
l'absence de raisonnement et donc quand
on sollicite l'émotion de l'utilisateur
ou du téléspectateur est bien en réalité
on neutralise sa capacité de recul
critique l'orim de l'émotion c'est ce
qui permet d'abolir
l'examen critique c'est ce qui permet
d'abolir le discernement et c'est ce qui
permet d'influencer les consciences dans
le sens de l'idéologie et cette
dictature de l'émotion elle s'inscrit
totalement dans cette logique de
manipulation des consciences c'est à
dire que pour faire réagir quelqu'un
pour le faire passer à l'action
ou pour lui faire prendre parti pour une
cause il sera toujours plus efficace
d'appuyer sur une zone
emotionnellement sensible que de le
faire réfléchir parce que la réflexion
suppose un effort parce que la réflexion
suppose de la patience et que l'homme
moderne est particulièrement
réfractaires à l'effort il est
réfractaire à la patience il veut que
les choses arrivent immédiatement et
surtout le moderne est persuadé que son
ressenti vaud comme une vérité ils tous
effectivement très dangereux parce que
derrière la manipulation des émotions
il y à la manipulation des consciences
il ya la manipulation d'opinion et donc
il y à l'asservissement intellectuelle
qui conduit à une véritable dictature
consentis c'est à dire que le propre des
dictatures émotionnel c'est qu'elles
n'ont pas besoin de passer par la
contrainte et par l'autorité pour
obtenir l'asservissement
l'asservissement et consenti parce qu'on
cède à ses émotions comme on cède à ses
pulsions
c'est à dire de manière spontanée par un
phénomène intérieure et le moderne a
souvent l'impression que tant qu'il
n'est pas contraint de l'extérieur ça
veut dire qu'il est libre il ne conçoit
pas que l'asservissement puisse être un
phénomène intérieur quelque chose qui va
être librement consentis parce que c'est
justement le résultat d'un phénomène
spontané mais je veux dire si vous
ajoutez un morceau de viande devant un
chien pour l'attirer à vous le chien va
se sentir parfaitement libres d'aller
vers le morceau de viande
donc ça évidemment ça nécessite de
redéfinir ce qu'on appelle la liberté de
bien distinguer conceptuellement la
liberté du foie c'est un clic
d'interroger la notion de consentement
de mettre en relation le consentement
avec l'aliénation c'est à dire le fait
que l'on puisse consentir à quelque
chose justement parce que l'on a été
manipulé et conditionnés à y consentir
et ça c'est un vaste chantier pour
lequel il me semble il est utile de
recourir à plus de philosophie question
suivante
es-tu matinale alors je te répondrais
que je ne suis pas matinale
naturellement mais que j'ai appris à le
devenir
il se trouve que j'ai occupé pendant mes
études
un emploi qui faisait que je devais me
lever à 2 heures du matin donc à ce
moment là de fait j'étais matinale mais
je n'étais pas par plaisir
je n'étais pas contrainte et aujourd'hui
je le suis redevenu là depuis le début
de cette année et je dois dire que je
n'ai qu'à m'en féliciter schopenhauer
disait que le matin c'était la jeunesse
du jour est il ce vrai que l'énergie
matinale est une énergie particulière à
la fois apaisante et en même temps
stimulante et j'ai l'impression d'être
beaucoup plus productif lorsque je me
lève tôt donc c'est une habitude que
j'ai prise et que je vais essayer de
conserver au maximum et son suivante
quels conseils encouragements réflexion
a changé votre vie
alors ça c'est une question à laquelle
il m'est difficile de répondre
quand on est enfant on entend souvent
les grandes phrases des adultes qui vous
invite à ne pas reproduire les mêmes
erreurs que ils vous diront par exemple
de tout faire pour avoir un métier qui
vous plaît ils vous diront de faire ce
qui vous rend heureux
sans vous soucier du jugement des autres
et du qu'en dira-t-on
et le fait qu'on grandisse avec ses
maximes avec ses phrases qui ont
tendance avec l'âge à être perçus comme
des poncifs voir comme des phrases
creuses comme des phrases vides de sens
en vieillissant ces phrases ont tendance
à ressurgir elles ont tendance à refaire
surface et à prendre tout leur sens
c'est un petit peu ça le le drame
lorsque l'on donne des conseils ou
lorsque l'on cherche à transmettre un
enseignement à quelqu'un qui n'a pas
encore terminé son parcours à quelqu'un
qui est encore en train d'évoluer en
train d'apprendre c'est que le conseil
qu'on va lui donner ne prendra sens pour
lui que lorsqu'il aura déjà parcouru le
chemin
autrement dit lorsque vous donner un
conseil à quelqu'un il est fort probable
que ce conseil ne résonne dans sa
conscience
une fois qu'il l'aura compris par lui
même c'est comme si on était
fondamentalement impuissant à
transmettre les enseignements que la vie
nous a donné parce qu'en réalité le
meilleur enseignement c'est celui qu'on
va déduire de notre propre expérience
alors oui parfois entendre un conseil ou
entendre une petite phrase qui a valeur
d'enseignement
ça va être utile mais ça n'aura
d'utilité que quand on sera soit même
parvenu à la même conclusion
et à ce moment là cette phrase va nous
revenir en mémoire et elle va nous faire
esquissé un petit sourire en disant
tiens
en fait c'était vrai et moi c'est ça que
j'aime beaucoup dans l'idée de
transmettre des enseignements c'est le
fait que j'ai parfaitement conscience
que cet enseignement n'aura aucune
portée tant qu'il ne sera pas le produit
de l'expérience de celui à qui je le
donne question suivante si tu avais le
pouvoir que conseillerais tu au charles
de 20 ans alors là on est justement pile
dans le prolongement de la question
précédente
eh bien je ne lui conseillerais
absolument rien aux charges de 20 ans
parce que le charles de 20 ans est une
tête d'enclumes qui n'écoutent rien ni
personne à part lui même donc je
pourrais lui dire n'importe quoi il
nommé coûterait pas il n'en fait qu'à sa
tête et il aurait parfaitement raison
qu'ils sont suivante blanc de brune
brune s'offrant la bière salle charles
que penses tu du complotisme liée à
l'explosion des réseaux sociaux
puisqu'il est désormais de bon ton de
donner son avis sur tout la vérité est
elle devenue une opinion comme une autre
alors j'aurai plusieurs choses à dire
d'abord que je ne suis pas d'accord pour
dire que le complotisme serait liée à
l'explosion des réseaux sociaux ce qui
est lié à l'explosion des réseaux
sociaux ce n'est pas le complotisme
c'est la visibilité du complotisme et le
complotisme selon moi il est d'abord le
produit de la perte totale de confiance
du peuple dans les gouvernants c'est à
dire qu'on ne devient pas complotistes
du jour au lendemain sans savoir
pourquoi
parce que l'envié vous en prend et puis
d'ailleurs le mot même de complotisme
c'est un mot absolument fourre tout dans
lequel on peut trouver absolument tout
et n'importe quoi c'est à dire qu'en
2003 si vous n'aviez pas confiance dans
le gouvernement américain
et dans colline powell qui a
littéralement fabriquer une preuve
chimique de la possession par saddam
hussein d'armes de destruction massive
qui a ensuite justifier une intervention
militaire américaine en irak
si vous n'aviez pas confiance dans cette
prétendue preuve vous étiez complotistes
et quand finalement colline powell a
révélé la vérité quelques années plus
tard dans une émission télé et que donc
il a donné raison à ceux qui n'avaient
pas eu confiance en lui est-ce que
c'était toujours du complotisme est-ce
qu'on peut encore parler de complotisme
quand les doutes que l'on aimait à
l'égard d'une version officielle se
révèlent justes par la suite
alors je sais très bien que certains
diront que avoir raison par intuition
c'est avoir raison pour de mauvaises
raisons parce que ça c'est un petit peu
l'argument qu'on entend régulièrement
pour discréditer toute démarche de mise
en doute toute démarche de méfiance à
l'égard de l'information officielle
on va dire que oui d'accord c'est vrai
ça s'est révélé juste par la suite mais
au moment des faits on n'avait pas de
preuve et donc si on n'avait pas de
preuves on avait tort de le croire et
finalement cet argument il est très
pratique parce que ça consiste à dire
que toute mise en doute d'une version
officielle quelle qu'elle soit et
forcément du complotisme parce qu'au
moment où on met une information en
doute
on n'est pas en mesure de prouver que
c'est une fausse information
donc par définition toute mise en doute
ce serait du complotisme et donc si le
simple fait de mettre en doute
c'est déjà du complotisme ça veut dire
qu'il ne faut rien mettre en doute
ça veut dire qu'il faut tout croire ça
veut dire qu'il faut renoncer à tout
examen à toute recherche à toute étude à
toute réflexion qui seraient
susceptibles d'aller vers une remise en
cause de la version officielle donc
lentilles complotisme primaire qui
consiste premièrement à mettre dans le
même sac conceptuel la remise en cause
par exemple des bonnes intentions du
gouvernement américain lorsqu'il
intervient militairement en irak et
mettre ça sur le même plan avec la
croyance selon laquelle emmanuel macron
et la reine d'angleterre seraient des
reptiliens
je suis désolé mais c'est cette
confusion là qui est ridicule le fait
d'homogénéiser de mettre sous la même
étiquette des démarches intellectuelles
des logiques d' analyse des systèmes de
croyances qui sont aussi éloignés que
les deux que je vous ai donné en exemple
c'est ça qui est une manipulation
donc moi je refuse d'accorder la moindre
valeur à ce pseudo concept de
complotisme qui n'est rien d'autre
qu'une arme rhétorique pour disqualifier
l'adversaire pour ne pas avoir à lui
répondre sur le fond
lorsque ces arguments sont pertinents ce
qui évidemment qu'il y aura toujours des
complotistes caricaturaux qui vont
défendre des thèses complètement farfelu
complètement grotesque et qu'il est bien
pratique d'ailleurs de pouvoir les
désigner du doigt pour dire que voilà ce
qu'est le complotisme et qu'à partir du
moment où vous remettez une version
officielle en cause vous vous assimilez
à ces personnes là vous vous assimilez à
cette manière de penser à cette
conception du monde qu'on appelle le
complotisme je suis pour la finesse du
langage je suis pour la nuance et pour
la précision est donc je refuse de me
plier à des catégories qui pour moi sont
des catégories complètement
manipulatoire question suivante comment
as tu réussi à arrêter de fumer en ne
décidant tout pousse combien en
développé couché alors au niveau de ma
charge de travail je suis à 90 kg et au
niveau de ma répétition maximale je suis
à 120 kg ce qui on va pas se le cacher
est une performance assez médiocre mais
compte tenu de mes 80 kg de poids de
corps et de mais bientôt 35 ans reste
pour moi une performance tout à fait
respectable traditionalistes ou
révolutionnaire alors patrick tu commets
si je puis me permettre ce qu'on appelle
un faux dilemme puisque ces deux
qualificatifs ne s'oppose pas dans une
société moderniste dans une société dont
le maître mot est le progrès la
tradition est révolutionnaire et là je
te renvoie si tu n'as pas encore eu
l'occasion de le lire au livre de jean
claude michéa qui explique parfaitement
en quoi cette opposition entre tradition
et révolution est une opposition qui n'a
plus lieu d'être aujourd'hui pour des
raison dialectique être traditionnels
aujourd'hui c'est être révolutionnaire
puisque c'est précisément aller à
l'encontre de ce
culte du progrès de ce culte du
modernisme qui est pour ainsi dire le
dogme des temps présents question
suivante la pulsion sexuelle est ce que
tu es d'accord avec la théorie de freud
2 alors je suis d'accord avec freud pour
dire que toute énergie trouve son
origine dans la pulsion sexuelle
je suis d'accord avec l'analyse que fait
freud de la sublimation qui est ce
processus de canalisations et de
détournement de l'énergie sexuelle vers
un acte de création
maintenant je ne partage pas les
convictions et les certitudes de freud
sur la question de la sexualité
infantile et on va dire que pour moi les
travaux de freud sont d'abord une source
de compréhension de l'articulation entre
les phénomènes du corps et les
phénomènes de l'esprit moi c'est ça qui
m'intéresse chez freud c'est cette
passerelle c'est cette idée de
complémentarité d'interconnexion
permanente entre le corps et l'esprit
que je trouve très intéressante mais
parce que je trouve que c'est une
question intéressante depuis spinoza et
même si on va aller plus loin depuis
platon puisqu'en réalité c'est une
question qui a été étudiée dès
l'antiquité et qui m'intéresse
particulièrement d'un point de vue
philosophique
donc je ne fais pas partie de ceux qui
vont considérer la psychanalyse ni comme
un dogme comme une vérité révélée mais
je ne vais pas non plus la considérer
comme étant purement et simplement une
escroquerie
je ne pense pas que dans la psychanalyse
tout soit a ajouté je ne pense pas que
tout soit balivernes
mais je pense que dans le corpus
freudien il a énormément d'affirmations
qui mériterait pour le moins une remise
en question critique et sont souvent tu
penses tu que l'homme soit de nature bon
ou mauvais donc là c'est une allusion
directe
je pense à ma vidéo sur rousseau ou bien
sûr up ou peut-être et 2 alors là dessus
je penche plutôt du côté de rousseau
c'est à dire que j'ai tendance à croire
et je parle bien de croyance parce que
je ne peux pas le vérifier et ce n'est
pas quelque chose qui relève d'une
connaissances scientifiques j'ai
tendance à penser que l'homme est
naturellement innocent c'est à dire que
à l'état de nature
l'homme ne se pose pas la question du
bien et du mal
je pense qu'il vivait en conformité avec
les lois naturelles et que les lois
naturelles elles ne sont ni bonnes ni
mauvaises alors parfois certes les
animaux peuvent être cruels entre eux de
même que je pense que les animaux sont
aussi capables d'altruisme
ils sont capables de sacrifices ce qui
prouve bien que dans la nature on trouve
les deux polarités on trouve à la fois
ce qu'on appellerait nous le bien et le
mal
et dire que c'est la société qui rend
l'homme mauvais c'est pas totalement
absurde dans le fond parce qu'on
s'aperçoit qu'il ya énormément de
comportement pervers ou de comportements
nocifs qui sont directement liés à des
problématiques de vie en société
la problématique de la reconnaissance la
problématique du jugement
la problématique de la confiance en soi
bien ça peut prédisposer à des
comportements nocifs des comportements
toxiques pour les autres donc de ce
point de vue là ne paraît pas absurde de
dire que dans une grande mesure
c'est la société qui nous rend mauvais
ou en tout cas que c'est l' influence de
notre vécu dans la société qui a pu nous
conduire à développer certaines
dispositions au mal question suivante
bonjour sharp récepteur une question
pour votre faq l'art est il comparable à
l'amour
alors ça c'est une jolie question est ce
que l'art est comparable à l'amour je
dirais que oui dans la mesure où l'art
c'est la création d'un fragment d'absolu
qu'est ce que ça veut dire un fragment
d'absolu ça veut dire que la
contemplation artistique et l'expérience
amoureuse se traduisent par les mêmes
effets c'est à dire le transport hors de
soi vers une sorte de transe en danse
je pense que c'est vraiment ça qui
réunit l'art et l'amour c'est une
expérience de la transcendance une
expérience du contact métaphysique
c'est ça pour moi le le point qui relie
l'art et l'amour
cette expérience métaphysique qui nous
met dans une situation où plus aucune
question n'a de raison d'être
c'est cette expérience de l'évidence
cette expérience de l'instant et
schopenhauer disait que être dans
l'instant c'était être plongé dans
l'éternité et cette expérience de
l'éternité on la retrouve dans l'art on
la retrouve dans l'amour et on la trouve
également dans l'expérience religieuse
c'est à dire dans la révélation qui sont
suivante
que fait un stoïcien lorsqu'il subit une
injustice de la vie dont il n'est pas
responsable
là je dirais qu un stoïcien il essaye de
comprendre d'abord l'injustice qui lui a
été faite et la comprenant ils
l'acceptent
ce qui ne va pas l'empêcher de se
prémunir pour ne pas avoir à la subir à
nouveau parce qu'en réalité le stoïcien
n'est pas dans une acceptation passive
face aux événements du monde
il est dans une acceptation active c'est
à dire qu'il est dans une démarche de
compréhension et dans une démarche
d'adaptation et d'anticipation le pire
contre sens qu'on puisse commettre ce
serait de croire que le stoïcien est
quelqu'un qui subit les événements
quelqu'un qui est passif face à ce qui
lui arrive
bien sûr que oui le stoïcien peut agir
bien sûr que oui le stoïcien doit agir
mais ne doit pas agir en s'illusionnant
sur son réel pouvoir d' influence le
stoïcien intervient là où il peut
intervenir là où c'est qu'il a un
pouvoir d'influencé
il ne va pas se bercer de chimères il ne
va pas se bercer d'idéaux utopique il va
prendre en compte la nature de la
réalité et agir sur elle en fonction de
son pouvoir
question suivante un contrat en anglaise
nietzsche contre yann barthès qui gagne
à mon avis nietzsche gagne par abandon
avant même que la cloche a sonné
quelques questions aimerais tu comptes
pause a alors là voilà une excellente
question pour le coup la question que
j'aimerais qu'on me pose ce serait de
savoir si dans mes anciennes vidéos
il y a des choses que je dirais
autrement des choses que je corrigerai
ou des choses que je regrette parce que
il est clair que quand on sort des
vidéos à intervalles réguliers pendant
un certain temps on fait un retour
critique sur ce qu'on a produit
et pour ma part j'ai tendance à être
extrêmement exigeants envers mon travail
envers la qualité de ce que je propose
au public et donc il m'arrive très
régulièrement lorsque je regarde une
ancienne vidéo de la trouvait totalement
nuls et de me dire que si je devais la
refaire aujourd'hui elle serait beaucoup
mieux ça je pense que c'est totalement
normal quand on est dans une dynamique
d'évolution dans une dynamique
d'amélioration de progrès je pense que
c'est tout à fait normal d'être dur
envers soi même être dur envers ce qu'on
a fait par le passé
à moins d'être dans une sorte d'auto
satisfaction reflète de soi même et de
considérer que tout ce qu'on fait est
forcément géniale est merveilleux c'est
pas mon cas c'est pas mon cas je suis
extrêmement sévère envers ce que je
propose
d'autant que j'ai le sens du détail donc
dès que quelque chose ne va pas je m'en
rends compte
et généralement c'est c'est une
sensation assez désagréable je sais que
dans certaines vidéos
j'ai commis des erreurs j'ai commis des
erreurs factuelles parfois par exemple
je me suis trompé de noms je me suis
trompé de date
j'ai fait des petites erreurs comme ça
qui sont des erreurs presque scolaire
j'allais dire parce qu' elle ne
remettait pas en cause le schéma général
d'exposition mais ce sont des petites
erreurs qui criblent en quelque sorte ma
production et ces erreurs là je les
assume je les assume
parce que je considère que la perfection
n'est pas de ce monde
je considère que ce n'est pas le mieux
qui est l'ennemi du bien mais le bien
qui est l'ennemi du mieux autrement dit
qu'à avoir un idéal inatteignable
on finit par ne rien faire et il ya
quelque chose que je combats
fondamentalement et c'est en partie le
sens de mon activité sur youtube ce que
je combats c'est la passivité
l'immobilier
sme l'inactivité qui très souvent va
prendre le costume de l'idéalisme c'est
à dire de la recherche de la perfection
une perfection que l'on sait être
inatteignable et qui donc va totalement
nous démobiliser moi je considère que la
vie c'est un brouillon qu'on ne recopie
ra jamais au propre donc sur un
brouillon on fait des erreurs et sur un
brouillon il y a des ratures et sur un
brouillon on trouve les traces de nos
va-et-vient de nos allers et retours de
nos hésitations et de no doubt et je
pense que c'est aussi ça qui rend la vie
intéressante le fait qu'elle ne soit
jamais une version eau propre
le fait que ce soit la longues
répétitions d'une pièce qui n'aura
jamais lieu
le fait que je dise que j'aurais aimé
qu'on pose cette question c'est pour
insister sur le fait que nous commettons
tous des erreurs et que c'est normal et
qu'il ne faut pas en avoir honte qu'il
faut l'assumer
parce qu'à partir du moment où vous êtes
sincère dans votre démarche
à partir du moment où vous faites
quelque chose avec le choeur avec votre
conviction avec la certitude de faire ce
qui est juste fait le fait le dès lors
que vous êtes dans une démarche
bienveillante
faites-le dès lors que vous êtes dans
une démarche constructive que vous
n'êtes pas animé par le ressentiment la
frustration la colère fait ce qui vous
semble bon et quand vous avez le temps
retournez vous sur ce que vous avez fait
et tenez compte de vos erreurs pour vous
améliorer
on peut pas à la fois agir et faire le
bilan de nos actions on doit d'abord
agir ensuite faire le bilan de nos
actions est le bilan de nos actions va
être une source d'enseignement pour nos
actions futures va être un fortifiant va
être le terreau sur lequel on va pouvoir
faire pousser des choses nouvelles et si
vous considérez qu'il ne faut pas agir
tant que l'on n'est pas sûr de faire
quelque chose de parfait je vous le dis
tout de suite vous n'agirait jamais vous
ne ferez jamais ce que vous avez envie
de faire et ça vous le regretterez
le regret est la pire chose qui puisse
connaître un être humain parce que c'est
un acide qui le ronge de l'intérieur et
qu'il ne peut jamais expulsé
tout simplement parce qu'on peut jamais
revenir en arrière et j'en reviens ce
que je disais tout à l'heure sur ces
petites phrases toutes faites qu'on
entend depuis l'enfance sur ces
enseignements que l'on entend que
lorsque l'on est prêt à les entendre
si je devais vous donné un seul conseil
aujourd'hui et je me permettre de le
faire c'est vive et de telle sorte que
vous n'ayez jamais à regretter
[Musique]